Speaker 1: All right, Mississippi is in real
trouble when it comes to the pandemic, and
they are not messing around.
They are now threatening five years in prison
for people who skip covid isolation if it
involves a life threatening situation.
So let's take a look at what is going on here.
Covid-19 patients must isolate or face fines
under the new Mississippi Department of Health
order as covid-19 cases across the state continue
to surge.
State health leaders are hoping a new order
will encourage people infected to self isolate.
Friday, state health officer Dr. Thomas Dobbs
handed down a mandate that all individuals,
vaccinated or not, who test positive must
stay home upon learning they are infected.
This is the key part.
Individuals who fail to do so could be charged
with a misdemeanor punishable by a fine of
five hundred dollars, six months imprisonment
or both upon conviction.
And then here's the key key line.
If a life threatening disease is involved,
failure to follow the order could result in
a failed felony charge, carrying a fine of
up to five thousand dollars five years in
prison or both.
The news comes as Mississippi continues to
report thousands of new infections daily and
as it leads the nation in new cases per 100000
inhabitants.
There are people saying this is crazy, this
is too much.
But understand what is happening in Mississippi,
Mississippi at baseline.
This is pre covid and during it, just aside
from covid, Mississippi is fiftieth out of
50 in health care rankings in the United States.
This includes access, cost and quality.
OK, Mississippi is also the second least vaccinated
state in the country.
There are ahead of only Alabama and even then
only by half a point.
Basically, Mississippi and Alabama are together.
The two least vaccinated states in the country,
Mississippi, is out of ICU beds.
As of two weeks ago when Dr. Leon Woodward
tweeted there were zero available ICU beds
in Mississippi as of early this morning, none.
That means hospitals across the state may
not be able to provide the level of care needed
to you or your loved one, not just for covid-19,
but for any emergency care.
Understand that this affects everybody.
This affects put covid aside.
This affects vaccinated people who get covid
and unvaccinated people who get covered.
But this affects people who just are driving
an activity that is not without risk.
And you get into a serious car accident and
you need an ICU.
And the ICU is full overwhelmingly because
of antifascists who have covered and are in
an ICU or whatever it is that leads to you
being at the hospital, the hospital will be
full.
So, yes, Mississippi is taking this seriously.
They're saying you risk five years in prison
if you test positive and don't isolate.
Now, meanwhile, by the way, Alabama hit negative
11 available ICU beds.
So exactly what that means varies.
Minus 11 could mean they have 11 people who
should be in the ICU, but there's no room
for them.
And there being some some other way accommodated.
Or it could mean that they have gone they've
basically set up 11 kind of like emergency
ICU type beds, even though they're not really
ICU beds.
Regardless, negative ICU availability is a
very, very bad thing.
So that's what's going on in Mississippi.
That's what's going on in Alabama.
And increasingly, we are seeing children,
children hospitalized with the virus.
So extremely serious stuff going on at good
for Mississippi for doing something.